okay hello everyone welcome to the final
ee 259 lecture for uh spring 2023 so
last time uh we started talking about uh
uh Imaging and vision systems for
cameras and we briefly talked about the
history of Imaging and now we're ready
to start talking about the physics of of
Imaging so as we did for other types of
sensors we we're going to start with the
with the principle uh of image formation
uh which is uh which is pretty simple as
you see uh in in this picture so uh
typically you have some some object out
in the field and then your Imaging
system or your camera consists of some
Imaging Optics uh which is uh a a an
assembly of lenses typically and then uh
rays of light basically pass through
your your Optics and come to focus on an
image sensor so uh this for instance
used to be a film in in traditional film
cameras but in the modern cameras these
are digital image sensors that we'll
talk about in detail and uh the sensor
basically or the digital uh Ms sensors
uh consists of of many pixels uh that
that measure light intensity uh and and
they can do that at different
wavelengths so uh um color cameras for
instance have pixels that measure uh
light intensity at red green and blue
wavelengths or RGB but you can also have
other types of cameras for instance
thermal cameras uh measure uh light
intensity at long wave IR
which is you know in in 6 to 12 Micron
range in wavelength and then what
happens after that basically there is
there is uh some some signal processing
engine or image signal processing engine
on the camera
called ISP for sure that collects the
signals from all the pixels and and
combines them and processes them to to
form an image which is which is what we
get out of the camera
um
so the first thing uh you might ask is
uh why do we need the lenses or the
Imaging Optics uh why can't we just uh
put the sensor uh and and in front of
the object and and have an image uh
formed on it and uh the reason is
basically explained and and then in this
uh picture here so uh without without
Optics what happens is that every every
sensor pixel would basically uh receive
Razer flight from every point on the on
the object and it would record basically
the integral of light arriving uh from
every Point uh on on this object uh so
then essentially what happens is that
all sensor pixels would record the
similar color and similar intensity so
you get a complete blur um and that's
for instance why uh we don't we don't
get images formed on on walls or or
other uh diffusely reflective surfaces
because there is there is no no Optics
every Point receives light from uh
everything out out there and and and
there is no image to be to be seen on
them so so that uh is is why uh we need
uh the the Imaging Optics and the the
basically the job of a properly designed
uh uh lens system is to make sure that
every Point uh in this object uh or the
Rays coming from uh every point in the
subject get focused properly on a point
in the image sensor the image plane and
then we get like a nice sharp image uh
formed
now at the core of uh the image
formation principle is this idea of
exposure so what exposure is
mathematically denoted by H it's it is
the amount of light uh energy per unit
area that that reaches uh the the
surface of of the of the image sensor
okay so there's two factors contributing
to to the exposure so our exposure is
the multiplication of basically the the
power density or the optical flux
density uh that is hitting the the
sensor uh surface uh that is denoted by
E and it's called irradiance in the uh
um in in the Optics uh field uh and it's
basically uh for us it is uh because we
know about the the theory of
electromagnetic waves uh the irradiance
is is basically the magnitude of the
pointing Vector which as we know is is
basically the uh power flux density of
an electromagnetic wave so it has a
units of watts per meters of squared so
that's the first factor that contributes
to the exposure and then the second one
is the the the time duration that every
pixel in the sensor is exposed to light
okay so that's T which is the exposure
duration uh so so we multiply irradians
by the exposure duration and that gives
the total exposure that is two factors
ENT uh they can be independently
controlled in an Imaging system so
irradiance is typically controlled by
the aperture size of the Optics or the
lens system right so the larger the the
aperture opening is more light is going
to be let through uh which which
increases the irradiance on the on the
image sensor surface and then uh
controlled by the shutter speed so uh
basically every system you can you can
set the the time duration that the
sensor is is exposed to light per frame
of image that you are you're capturing
um so so then because you can you can
control these two factors independently
um then for the set amount of exposure
you can have different combinations of
aperture size and shutter speed that
that give you the same exposure so you
can increase your aperture size and
reduce the shutter speed or the other
way around reduce aperture size and
increase shutter speed and keep exposure
the same uh but it turns out that uh
doing uh like changing the aperture size
and the and the and the shutter speed
while keeping exposure is the total
exposure the same would have very
different effects on the on the on the
final image that you get uh specifically
uh what increasing the aperture size
does uh to to the image is that it
reduces the depth of field okay so here
if we look at the two images on the top
row so these are two images captured of
the same scene and between the two
images the total exposure is the same as
you can see the colors look the same the
the intensity looks the same so it's the
same exposure but what has changed
between the two is that the left one has
a large aperture opening and the right
one is has a small aperture opening
which means to keep the exposure the
same the left one had a faster shutter
speed or smaller exposure duration and
the right one had a longer exposure
duration but because the scene was a
stationary that that at the time didn't
have an effect on the final image but
the effect of the aperture opening as
you see in the in the left one that the
background is completely blurred versus
in the right one uh we get like a nicely
sharp focused background and that's the
idea of depth of field so we'll talk
more about it but the general trade-off
is large aperture openings lots more
light through but reduces the depth of
field and the depth of field is roughly
uh speaking is uh basically the range of
uh distances for which the subjects will
be in focus in the final image now uh
let's talk about reducing shutter speed
so reducing shutter speed at the effect
that it will have is that it will
increase motion blur
in the final image so if we look at the
bottom row here again that there's two
pictures of the same scene with the same
amount of exposure but between the two
the left one has a slow shutter speed
and the right one has a fast rotor speed
and here the scene unlike the top one
was not stationary so the hand and the
hammer we're removing as the shot was
taken and the slow shutter speed causes
as you can see significant motion blur
in the scene versus The Fast Tracker
speed uh kind of like freezes the moving
subjects in place and and
um
uh basically uh makes a sharper final
image uh the the depth of field effect
is also there like if you look very
closely the one with the slow shutter
speed to keep the exposure the same it
means that the aperture size was a
smaller and if you look at the
background the wood grains are are more
in focus in this one compared to the
right one which is kind of it it looks a
little softer or more out of focus and
and that's the the depth of field effect
so these effects always exist and go
hand in hand and
um so so so what's the the right choice
well it depends on the application it
there's really no right or wrong here it
really depends on like do you care more
about depth of field or do you care more
about the sharpness and the motion blur
uh and for your application and what is
the right uh trade-off uh to to to make
there okay
um now when it comes to exposure itself
it turns out that there is always for
every given scene for the given you know
dynamic range in the live wedding
conditions there's always a correct
amount of exposure so that's the total
energy density of the light that hits
the sensor within one frame and and
that's the correct exposure is such uh
Set uh such that
um basically uh the highlights and the
shadows in the in the in that scene uh
kind of show nicely in the in the final
image so if we if we do uh less than the
correct amount of exposure so if the
underexpose the image that's the case
where not enough Light reaches the
sensor and in that case uh especially
the Shadows would look too dark or maybe
completely black and we lose all the
details there which is the case uh in in
this image you see like the darker areas
there's not a lot of detail because of
underexposure and then
um on the the the the ope side of it is
the case of uh overexposure and that's
where there's too much light uh reaching
the sensor and in that case the
highlights or the right regions of the
of the image I can get
washed out or completely saturated if
you hit the dynamic range of the of the
sensor and then we lose all detail as is
the case in this right uh image as as
you can see you know the the sky and the
the bright areas of the scene are
completely washed out and then we have
lost all detail and then this middle one
has the correct amount of exposure where
everything is is nicely exposed
um now um it's it's not like there's
just one value of exposure that that is
uh correct I mean uh if you look uh like
this this uh uh one to the to the right
and to the left of the the the middle
one and there it one is a slightly
Overexposed the other one is slightly
underexposed but still you can make out
all the details in the scene so so there
is you know there's a bit of a margin
there and uh especially when it comes to
Artistic photography you know different
people have different tastes like I'm I
myself I'm not a big artist but when I
take photos uh I tend to underexpose a
little bit because I I like to
exaggerate the the Shadows a little bit
uh now uh when it comes to autonomy
modern cameras uh uh almost all of them
have uh algorithms that try to uh but by
by you know some some uh sensing from
the scene from like the total intensity
that they're getting and things like
that uh with some heuristic algorithms
they try to automatically set the
correct exposure level and
if cases it works reasonably well but
they're not perfect and certain cases
especially scenes with very high dynamic
range they need to you know make a
trade-off or sometimes they just flat
out uh make a make a wrong decision so
just note that auto exposure exists and
then all modern cameras but it's it's
it's never perfect but it works
reasonably well and and most uh most
cases
okay so so that's about the high level
physics of Imaging as we said a big part
of a very important part of any Imaging
system is the Imaging Optics or the
lenses so now we're going to talk a
little more uh about uh about lenses if
you remember we did talk about the
lenses in the context of lidar and
gaussian beams and the importance of
lenses for you know proper collimation
of of beams uh here we're gonna
look at lenses for different application
which is image formation and we're gonna
develop a different framework which is
more useful for uh understanding the the
physics of Imaging and the framework is
called geometric optics as as we'll see
but at a high level again what what a
lens system or Imaging Optics does for
us as is shown in this bottom example is
that it makes sure that every point on
your subject or the Rays of light that
are coming uh
from uh from that point they nicely get
converged or focused on a point in the
image plane and that means we get you
know a nice refocused sharp image form
versus anything else that you try to do
I mean we talked about having no lens at
all and then you get just a complete
layer you can't even you don't even have
an image but other things like if if you
put like a tiny pinhole
um
and and try to you know just just
restrict the small rays of light to go
through that even a small pinhole is
it's not going to be perfect there's
going to be you know every Point that's
going to form a small spot instead of
you know a nicely focused point in the
image and then you get you know with a
pinhole you get a a blur blurred image
just just to note I mean pinhole
photography is a thing and there is
techniques that that can can make very
nice images with pen holes but they come
with very very big trade-offs so in
practice I mean for for uh artistic
photography they're used but in practice
you know for sensing application nobody
uses pinhole cameras basically everybody
uses cameras with uh with Optics
um okay so
um with that uh when it comes to
um understanding
um the the the properties of lenses and
their their importance uh there are two
main physical parameters of lenses that
basically affect the quality and the
characteristics of the images that are
formed first is the focal length and uh
focal length as we'll see determines the
field of view of the camera you know
um what what what uh Azimuth and
elevation field of view you get in an
image and then there is the second
parameter which is called the F number
or n uh for the for the lens and the F
number as we'll see it determines the
effective aperture size and as we
briefly talked uh um aperture size
affects the depth of field
right and and we'll we'll talk in more
detail about this but uh at a high level
the focal length and the and the and the
F number uh together determine the field
of view and the depth of field of of the
image that that you're going to get but
there's other lens parameters that uh
some lenses have these some don't but
generally speaking you can have fixed
versus variable focal length uh lenses
um so
um fixed focal length lenses are called
prime lenses and then zoom lenses are
the ones where um you can you can vary
the focal length uh every lens has a
minimum Focus distance so uh if a
subject is closer than that to the lens
it just cannot focus on it and and you
would always no matter what you do get a
blurred uh image some Modern lenses have
active image stabilization so this is
um I'm kind of like an active mechanical
system that moves around some of the
optical elements inside the lens to
cancel out vibrations
it's kind of a
relatively fancy thing so many many
lenses that used in robotics they just
don't have it
um but but some uh more complex ones do
and then there are lenses that that have
uh perspective control uh you might have
heard of uh like tilt shift lenses uh
and these are mostly used for uh
artistic photography and and not really
for autonomy applications so we are not
gonna
cover this uh we will mostly talk about
these two characteristics of the lenses
we want to understand the focal length
and the F number and how exactly did
they determine field of view and and the
aperture size okay as I said the
framework we will use to to analyze uh
lenses is called geometric optics so
what geometric optics is is basically
it's an extension of this idea of
paroxyl wave approximation which we
developed as we were talking about
gaussian beams and lidars and now it
turns out that you can extend that idea
uh uh in in the cases where the
wavelength Lambda is is a small compared
to the size of the optical components uh
you can extend the paroxyl wave
approximation to the to the to what is
called the geometric optics and what
happens in the geometrics Optics regime
is that it we we now are sort of
thinking of of light as as as a wave we
just think model light as uh as a
straight race and that that just travel
in straight paths and in homogeneous
media and these Rays uh they do Bend at
the interface between two dissimilar
media and by the similar we mean like
media that are different materials or
have a different refractive indices for
instance they can they can bend these
rays of Light which is exactly what for
instance a lens does but just note that
the geometric optics it's very useful to
to for instance understand image image
formation physics
but it's it's an approximate framework
so for instance some effects such as
diffraction or interference are
completely ignored in the geometric
optics framework
um and again it it also completely be
and that's because it completely ignores
that wave nature of Light which is as we
know it's that that's the underlying uh
physics
um but but nevertheless the framework is
extremely useful for the purpose of uh
you know understanding Imaging systems
and that's what we're going to use
so um when it comes to uh lenses and in
this geometric optics uh framework the
operation of of lenses or at least I
should say ideal lenses for now
we can add non-idealities to the
behavior ideal lenses also called thin
lenses they behave very simply so uh the
way they're modeled is that if you have
some parallel rays of light as as shown
here that uh basically our incident on
the lens they get converged to a point
that is a focal length F
behind the the lens so you basically
take the the center of the lens and then
a focal length F away from it all the
parallel rays are converged to that that
one point so that's that's one
um uh basically main result that comes
out of the the geometric optics uh and
then the other thing
related to geometric optics and and and
lenses is that if you have rays that go
through the so-called optical center of
the lens those Rays would not be
deviated so they just go straight
through and for ideal lenses or or thin
lenses
um
the the optical center is basically just
the geometric center of the lens right
uh and then again as shown here the Rays
that that uh
are are pointed towards the optical
center just go straight through with
with no bending or anything like that uh
now with just these two uh um principles
uh it turns out that we can fully
analyze uh like how image formation
works at least with ideal lenses but
before that we need to discuss uh how
how this this what the focal length is
and how it's related to the geometry uh
of of of of the ideal or the thin lens
so um the ideal lens that it's the
geometry is is is uh very simple
um so um for instance if you have a
double convex lens uh the geometry is is
is just described by the the the the
radii of curvature of the two surfaces
so you have a curvature Radia radius of
curvature rl1
um for for for the you know the the the
the the convex uh surface and you have
rl2 for the for the concave uh surface
um so those are the two uh radiative
curvature note that the convention here
is that the radius of the radius of
curvature for convex surfaces it's taken
to be positive and for concave surfaces
is taken to be negative so in this case
um this surface is the convex surface so
rl1 is positive and rl2 is uh negative
uh because this second surface is the
concave surface as as the Rays you know
going in this direction uh now with this
definition and this geometry and the
focal length is a function of the two
radii of curvature and also the
refractive index of the lens material
which could be glass or plastic or or
other materials and and this is the
equation so 1 over f is n minus 1 times
1 over rl1 a minus 1 over rl2 and
remember that the the refractive index n
is the square root of the relative of mu
R times Epsilon r ver mu R is the
relative uh
and permittivity and Epson has a
relative permeability which is equal to
um C over V over C is the as the speed
of light in vacuum and V is the speed of
light inside the material the lens
material so that's the speed
of light
inside
the lens whatever that material is
um so so basically light gets slowed
down by a factor of n when it's inside
when it's traveling inside the inside
the lens okay so that's how for a for
um you know a simple ideal lens like a
double convex lens how how you can find
the the focal length okay now uh with
that
and with the two principles that uh we
talked about about you know parallel
rays hitting the lens getting converged
to a point of focal length behind and uh
raised that that hitting the
um optical center going straight through
uh now we can kind of have a very
simplified model uh using geometric
optics of how image formation uh works
so uh here we assume we have this this
this ideal lens and then it's a 2d
picture but it works the same in in 3D
so so we have some some object or a
point on an object shown by at the tip
of this this Arrow basically and uh the
the the the Rays that are rays of light
that are coming from from that uh object
basically all of them get converged to a
point on the image plane
um so that they all basically get get
get focused and again the the parallel
ones uh that that hit the lens they go
through uh the the focal point of the
land so that's that's the point which is
a distance F away and then the the rate
that is going through the optical center
goes right through and then the point of
intersection of those points uh of those
Rays is is basically the focus point on
the on the on the image point and any
other array that that we basically
launch from from that uh Target is is is
going to go
and the ideal case through the same same
Focus point so all the Rays basically
get converged and and uh one point and
this this this uh basically method of of
analyzing image formation it's also
called gases uh Ray tracing image
construction okay now in this geometric
view
um um we need to basically understand
the the the the the the main thing is
kind of like the distance between the
object to the lens and the distance
between the image to the lens so we need
to be able to find those distances as
well as basically uh the the the
height of the the the image Point
relative to the height of the object
which is kind of like a magnification
Factor if you will
okay
Now by a pure geometric analysis and uh
by this I mean just looking at looking
at similarities of triangles and things
like that which I I won't go go through
it but it's a very simple uh geometric
analysis uh we can come up with the
gaussian lens formula which relates the
uh distance between the the lens plane
and the object and the distance between
the lens plane and the image and the
focal length of the lens and it's given
by this very famous simple formula which
is 1 over s i s i is the object distance
to the lens plus one over so where so is
the image a distance to the lens equals
one over the focal length one thing to
note is that these quantities s i and so
these are signed distances and for s i
the positive is rightward right so in
this specific picture s i is positive so
is also positive but for for SL positive
is left one now for very specific cases
um like special types of lenses uh SI
for instance can become negative and
that's where we have like a virtual
image that is formed in front of the
lens instead of behind the lens so just
note that that those are signed uh
quantities with with different Positive
Directions and also we can find by again
a purely geometric you know uh type of
analysis the ratio between y i which is
the the height of the image point to the
Y O which is the height of the object
point and we call that Mt which is the
lateral magnification Factor so that's y
i over y o and y i and y o are also
signed quantities and here uh positive
is upward for both of them okay so with
that uh convention y o is positive y i
is negative because the image always
comes flipped relative to the to the
object and because of that y i is
negative so um the the Magnificent the
lateral magnification while I were over
y o uh becomes equal to negative s i uh
over over so
and uh again these things like uh these
these uh equations are very simple to
derive maybe just uh like um just just
to convince you like these are from Pure
geometry like this one you get it just
by the similarity of these two triangles
that I'm going to highlight in blue so
this one
and this one
these are two similar triangles and uh
um the the the sides are uh of length y
i and y o and then this is s o and s-i
so just by similarity that that gives
you this equation here
um okay
very good so so so so so that's uh
basically what the geometric optics uh
framework how uh image formation Works
uh but uh uh the the question uh you
might ask is um what if they're not
working with a simple thin lens uh what
if you're working with a optical system
that contains many lenses and that's the
case for many modern Optical systems
like even you know small tiny digital
cameras uh like the ones in the phones
these days have
um Optics that are that consist of like
multiple lenses four five six or so uh
lenses go into it and those
um are are not the simple you know
picture that that we analyzed here and
and they're called or they can be
modeled as the whole you know Optical
assembly containing all the lenses can
be modeled as one thick lens okay and
thick lenses can be characterized by a
few parameters we are not going to go
through the full details so instead of
just the focal length and you know the
radius of curvature there's multiple
parameters that go into you know the
description of or or the model of a
thick lens so there is like the
secondary principle playing the primary
principle plane
um and uh basically so so in a way uh
you have you know a different focal
point F Prime behind the lens then and
another one uh in front of the lens with
different you know distances so you have
F Prime and F but at the end of the day
um again there's a link here that that
describes the full you know
characterization and the model of the
thick lens but the the the the the same
Ray tracing principles apply to the to
the thick lenses so if you have an
object and then you you basically uh
trace the Rays of light that that come
out of a point and and the object they
do get converged to a point uh on an
image plane so so essentially at the end
of the day it's it's it's the same
principle of image formation but the
geometry and the you know and the the
model becomes a slightly more slightly
more complicated not even too too much
complicated okay so so everything we we
talked about we did it for like a simple
thin lens but bear in mind that that it
it applies to a more complex Optical
systems also
okay so so so one thing I'm going to
just go back to this picture here and um
clean this up a little bit so so if you
look at this discussion lens formula
here this one
this is telling us something very
important again if we go beyond the math
right
um and and just uh think about what it
means right what is what what does this
imply about the the physics of Imaging
uh one thing we can see here is that if
we fix the focal length f
okay and we also fix the position of our
image sensor meaning S Sub I is fixed we
just have you know a sensor at a fixed
position relative to the lens and and
that's s i and and that is fixed and
we're not going to to to change that
with those two parameters fixed that
means so would also become fixed the so
that that solves this equation becomes
fixed and what that means is that for a
lens of fixed focal length and a fixed
position of the image sensor only
objects in one specific
plane out in the field would become
perfectly focused in the image plane
any object with an so that is not the
one that solves this equation would be
out of focus so if you have another
object slightly you know in front or
slightly behind that that main object
those two still form something on the
image plane but it's not going to be in
perfect Focus okay and that's a very
very important uh principle uh to to to
to to note
okay so
um so then what can we do uh to to
change that Focus distance so if you
want to you know bring objects at
different distances from the lens into
Focus what should we do okay if the lens
has a fixed focal length F uh again
for that only objects at a specific
distance are in Focus so in order to
focus on objects at different distances
we need to move the sensor right so
relative to the lens uh so so so we have
to move the the sensor relative to the
to the lens and and that's the picture
uh that's that's shown here so when the
when the sensor is uh exactly at the
focal plane of the lens so that's where
s i equals to F if you go back to our
gaussian lens formula which was 1 over s
i plus one over so equals one over F
that means 1 over so should be zero
which means so equals infinity so when
the sensor is at the focal plane of the
lens we are focusing at Infinity
okay
that's one case now as you start moving
your sensor back uh the focus plane
starts getting closer and closer to the
to the lens right you move your sensor
even further back now your focus plane
is is closer and then at some point
you basically uh if if the focus plane
is at the focal length so if so equals F
that means S I should equal Infinity so
that means you have to put your sensor
infinitely be away from your lens to be
able to focus at the the the the
focal a focal length in front of the the
lens which basically means you cannot do
that so can you cannot focus on objects
closer to the lens than its focal length
right and and that's kind of like that's
that idea of the minimal minimum Focus
distance for for for a giveness okay so
so this is important uh to note that in
order to focus at different planes um in
the field you need to move the sensor
relative to the lens another way of
thinking about it which I I really
really like this this this this this way
of of thinking about it which is given
in this box here is that uh lenses
actually transform a a 3D object or a 3D
scene into a 3D image so the actual
image that is formed behind the lens is
a 3D image right uh but because we have
a 2d sensor just a sensor in a plane we
can only extract the 2D slice from that
image right and that slice is where you
put
put your image so we just extract the 2D
slice from a 3D image and in that slice
only objects that correspond to a
specific distance from the lens in the
physical world are in focus and
everything else that is closer or
further away is going to be out of focus
that's that's another way of thinking
about it okay so that's about changing
the focus distance
another thing
um we need to discuss is what about
changing the focal length okay and you
can change the the focal length by
changing the lens entirely or as we said
some zoom lenses uh have moving Optical
elements inside them and with a um with
for instance with a ring or some other
uh control mechanism you can you can
vary the focal length of the lens uh in
some range
so uh lenses that have larger or longer
focal lengths those are called weak
lenses because they Bend bend the light
less okay so weak lenses have have
longer focal lengths and
um and as you see in this picture so
here uh we have this we have a system
and first we were using a lens with a
focal length of say three inches and
then to bring this this plane in Focus
which is where the tree is we had to you
know place our sensor at certain
distance away now if you use a weaker
lens uh and and
keeping everything else the same so now
we go to a focal length of six inches
for instance in order to focus on the
same image plane we need to move the
sensor further back again because this
is a weaker lens and it's bending the
Rays of light less so the point that
those Rays converters are now going to
be further away uh from the lens okay
but another thing that happens which is
very important here uh is that okay so
we need to move the sensor back with the
longer focal length to get to focus on
the same subject basically but if the
size of the sensor Remains the Same
which is almost always the case okay now
we're gonna have a smaller field of view
as as you saw from see from these Ray
tracing here so at the top one you know
the field of view is like the topmost
pixel on the on the uh image we just
pass it through the optical center of
the lens and that's hitting you know
kind of the base of the tree and the
bottom pixel if you trace the ray that's
hitting that it's it's getting the top
of the tree so our field of view covered
the entire tree right now what the
weaker lands and the same sensor plays
further back if we trace the array from
the top and bottom most pixels we'll see
that it only covers the midsection of
the tree so that means I feel a few got
reduced right so that's that's the
effect of changing the focal length as
you increase the focal length the fov
goes down or another way to think about
it it's kind of like a zooming effect
right now about the longer focal length
just just the center piece of the the
tree is going to cover your entire
sensor so it's kind of like you're
you're zooming in and that's why uh
these these lenses with variable focal
lengths call are called zoom lenses
uh here's a picture I'm showing for
instance for uh how how this effect
works so here uh we have we have a fixed
scene so that's that's the scene that's
some you know uh like a harbor
um but with with some buildings and and
and people and and and and and ships
around it and uh the the camera was
placed at a fixed position in the harbor
and this the subject or the scene is
also constant and all we are changing is
the focal length so zoom lens was used
and and the focal length was changed so
first we start with a short focal length
of 17 millimeter uh which which gave us
a very wide field of view so as you see
here 17 millimeter can uh basically that
gave us 104 degrees field of view and
then uh we start you know uh kind of
zooming in or or increasing the the
focal length so as you go from 17
millimeters to 50 millimeters and now
your field of view gets reduce and it
only gets roughly if I can get it here
it only gets like this part of uh of the
of the of the scene so so that's what
you get from a 50 millimeter uh field of
view now if you go from 50 millimeters
to 135 millimeters you further zoom in
and now you only get maybe
um something like this part of the scene
right and that's what this picture is uh
right so you're reducing the field of
view sensor size is constant so it feels
like you're zooming in right
and then if you go from 135 to 500
millimeters so now we are at 18 degrees
right now if you go to 500 millimeters
we further zoom in to something like uh
just just this
uh and that's that's what uh we get and
that's just a five degree field of view
so so so you see as we went from 17
millimeters to 500 millimeters we
reduced our field of view by uh almost a
factor of uh 20 right about 20x down
um so it's a kind of a non-linear effect
between uh focal length and and uh field
of view and it also depends on your
sensor size
um so so it's not this this ratio yeah
it's it's it can it can be different for
different lenses and different sensors
but that's the high level effect of you
know how changing the focal length
affects the final image it basically
controls your field of view or Zoom
Factor
okay
um so that's about
that's about equal length and the effect
it has on the on the pictures uh the
second important lens parameter as we
said is that is the F number which
controls the aperture size so the F
number n of a lens uh with aperture
diameter a is given by this so n is the
focal length divided by the aperture
diameter so the aperture diameter
remember it's typically circular for
lenses and then a is the diameter uh so
so F over a is the half number of the
lens
um so for instance a f number that is f
over 2 on a 50 millimeter focal length
lens means that the aperture diameter is
25 millimeters
okay
so
um
remember one of the factors that affects
the
um total exposure of of uh pixels on the
image is is a Radiance or E and
irradians is proportional to two factors
one is basically the total area of the
of the aperture opening so the total
area of this circle
okay that's one thing so that's
basically how much light is is coming
through and the area is proportional to
the square of the diameter right uh so
so again this is Aperture area
or proportional to aperture area uh and
and that's fixed irradiance and the
second thing that affects the radiance
is it it's inverse
proportional to the inverse square of
the distance between the sensor and the
and the lens aperture right and the
distance as we know it varies it depends
on you know where we are focusing at but
roughly speaking it's about a focal
length it's kind of usually close to F
it's not exactly yes but it's it's close
to F okay so our total irradiance then
is from from these two is proportional
to a squared times uh one over F squared
right and then from this formula it
means it's proportional to 1 over N
squared or the F number squared right
right so that's how our F number affects
the total irradiance or the total you
know light energy per unit area that
hits the it's the sensor uh within one
frame so increasing our F number by a
factor of K would reduce the irradians
by K squared okay and that's a that's an
important important trade-off to note
now as we set the aperture diameter or
aperture size a affects the depth of
field
in the image and and that's one thing we
need to you know study and quantify and
exactly first Define what we mean by
depth of field and then how we quantify
it and how it's affected by the aperture
size
so um the weight of the field is is
defined is
um kind of this idea of of
um using this idea of permissible circle
of confusion so remember that we just
argued that for any given Imaging system
only points in just one object plane
which is at a very specific distance
from the lens will be perfectly focused
in image right so
for a given focal length given distance
between the sensor and the lens uh only
one object plane one so would come to
perfect Focus okay and points in any
other plane or any other distance from
the lens will form spots in the image
instead of like getting focus to points
they form you know spots on the image
but it turns out that for all practical
purposes
if those spots are small enough we can
consider them almost in Focus okay and
that's this idea of permissible circle
of confusion or C which is the size of
the the spot on the image that is
considered acceptably sharp okay or
almost in focus
and let's see
um there's no you know formula that we
can give and say oh okay so this is how
you calculate C and you know if if any
spot is smaller than this it's in focus
and logic and this it's it's blurred it
depends on a lot of factors so uh it
depends on the sensing medium it depends
on the reproduction medium like is it
printed is it on a display is it on a
projector is it on a TV it really
matters the viewing distance also also
matters like how close are we you know
um depends on the even the the you know
the the
vision of the of the of the human who's
looking at it you know how how good uh
their their vision is and and other
factors right so it's it's quite uh
subjective you know what at the end of
the day what uh what the circle uh
permissible circle of confusion is but
um typically for digital sensors C is
taking to be the size of one pixel which
for instance it for different sensors is
different but for instance for a DSLR
camera it's about six microns okay
that's what what is taking so if the
spot is less than this
pixel size again because that's our unit
of measurement we can't even measure
anything that's less than the pixel size
so we just call it okay that's perfect
Focus which kind of makes sense and now
in other cases it can be that that you
know C is taken to be more than a pixel
but that's that's
um you know
uh typical and this this C can then be
used to determine the depth of field
called D and the depth of field is
basically a range of distances from the
lens that all subjects that fall within
the type range of distances are uh you
know reasonably in Focus or acceptably
sharp and that's what we call the depth
of field so
um
here this picture is kind of you know
illustrates this this this concept of
permissible circle of confusion so if we
start at the and look at the middle uh
uh of the picture first so here's you
know the object plane at which the
points come to a perfect focus on the
sensor so this is our sensor plane and
that's our object plane that that you
know is is perfectly image so so then
this is the if if that's our excuse me
uh lens plane this is our so and this is
our SI right and and that's that's
perfect and and you get like a perfect
point
perfect focus on the image plane now for
objects that are closer or further away
as we said as we argued what what what
they form on the on the image plane is
the spots right and this if these spots
are are smaller than or equal in
diameter to C which is the permissible
circle of confusion we call them
acceptably sharp right uh same for for
objects that are you know further
further away uh they're gonna form spots
and if the spot is smaller than or equal
to C in size we call it acceptably sharp
so with that that means we can then have
a range of distances which we call D or
depth of field uh and and of course the
object plane
is within that uh uh depth depth of
field the you know the perfectly focused
object plane but everything that's
within uh within D out in the field is
you know is is considered reasonably
sharp and in focus in the in the final
image okay so how do we calculate the uh
well it turns out that again just just
like we did the uh um
gaussian uh Imaging formula uh with with
pure pure geometric arguments uh we can
also
um uh you know quantify what the depth
of field is for a given permissible
circle of confusion
um so here's the the the the the the
picture here
um and and again D is the distance
between the nearest and the furthest
objects that are acceptably sharp uh
uh focused in the in the image or if
they form spots that are no bigger than
than C and and size okay
um and we are not going to go through
the full you know geometric analysis but
note that it's pure geometry
um done here to derive what uh what D is
so um in this picture kind of um shows
the the so on the image plane this is
the permissible circle of confusion
that's the the green is the the diameter
of it and then uh you can translate that
to uh what is called the conjugate
of a circle of confusion
uh which which will have a diameter that
is C divided by MTN remember Mt is the
lateral magnification Factor okay and
um the lateral magnification factor it's
it can be roughly approximated by U over
F where U here as you see is the
distance from the lens to the to the
perfectly focused object plane
that's U and F is the focal length
um so so the the this this you know the
the conjugate circle of confusion has
diameter C over F and then this diamond
shape basically area
that is kind of for the the the distance
the distances of the two ends of it from
the lens that's what our depth of field
is right so from our our image plane you
can come forward a distance D1 and you
can go back a distance D2
uh and and you would remain in Focus
that's the idea and notice that it's
asymmetric right so the
um the the the the perfect uh object
plane is not in the center of the depth
of field that's very important right so
it's it's like this diamond that's has
as asymmetry in it specifically after
you know solving the geometry D1 uh we
can show is is equal to this which is n
times c times U squared where n is the F
number c is the permissible circle of
confusion you remember is the you know
the distance between the InFocus object
plane and the lens divided by F squared
plus NC over f is the focal length so
that's D1 and D2 uh is is given by this
other expression which is ncu squared
divided by F squared minus ncu okay so
again note the asymmetry in the in the
um uh depth of field
so what is the total depth of field
that's just D1 plus D2 uh we add the two
and this is our final formula for uh the
total depth of field that we get for and
it's it's a function of many parameters
right you see the
um the F number n goes in it the of
course the circle of confusion goes in
it the the distance to the left from the
lens to the in Focus object plane goes
in it and the focal length goes in it
right so all of these parameters at the
end of the day can affect our depth of
field now this formula this is this is
you know the most accurate version of it
but in many cases uh it turns out that
the the conjugate of the circle of
confusion which has the size C over Mt
is a small relative to the lens aperture
a which is f over n and in those cases
this N squared c squared U squared term
in the denominator can be ignored okay
and then we get a simpler
expression uh which is this so that the
depth of field is approximately equal to
2 and CU squared over F squared okay so
let's remember that this one is
approximate but it's a very good
approximation for in many practical
applications but you should always check
that like this is is this condition is
is C over Mt
you know smaller than a or not uh if if
not you should use the more accurate
version okay
now with this uh
see you know as we said there's multiple
factors affecting depth of field number
one is is is an or the or the F number
as we saw before it does affect the
depth of field and it affects it
linearly so right so it's linear in in F
number uh it's quadratic in U which is
distance from the lens to the to the in
in Focus object plane and it's in Risk
quadratic in the focal length right so
if any of these parameters changed in
the in our Imaging setup it's going to
affect the depth of field let's look at
some examples we start with uh F number
so as we said depth of field varies
linearly with aperture size
um which is controlled by the F number
right so here's uh two pictures of the
same scene taken with different aperture
sizes so first one we were doing n is f
over 2 which is a large aperture and
then the second picture is taken with uh
and is f over 16 so we reduce the
aperture size by a factor of 8.
so it went
8X down right or I should I should
really say one over eight right that's
that's how how much we reduce the
aperture size by one over one over eight
right
um
and uh we know the depth of field is
linear in N so increasing n by a factor
of eight right so increased n by a
factor of eight which means aperture
went down by a factor of eight should
increase our depth of field by a factor
of eight roughly and that's exactly the
case so we kept everything else the same
so U which is the you know the distance
to the to the plane of of of in Focus
plane uh that was kept the same so in
both cases we were focusing on the face
of this middle person uh in the scene so
to keep the U the same focal lengths the
same everything was the same and with
the small aperture uh the depth of field
was just about one foot so as you see
just the main target that we focused on
is in focus and then object in the front
and there's third person in the back
they're both completely out of focus and
then we increase n by a factor of 8 or
reduce that aperture size by a factor of
eight and and now we have a depth of
field of eight feet
again U is the same so it's important to
just change one parameter here so that's
U but now with the with the depth of
field of eight feet all three subjects
are are reasonably sharp and and in
Focus the middle person the front person
and the back person the bad person maybe
it's not that perfect but it's it's
still reasonably sharp like compared to
what we had originally okay so that's
the effect of aperture size and on depth
of field the other two parameters that
affect it as as as you know is
um the focal length and U which is
distance from the infocused plane to the
object let's look how those affected so
uh depth of field varies inverse
quadratically with focal length and
that's Illustrated in this two pictures
on the top row so here again it's the
same scene you know same lighting and
everything and uh we have only changed
the uh focal length of of the lens that
that was used so this one has a long
focal length 135 millimeters and this
picture is taken with a shorter focal
length 50 millimeters and depth of field
is inversely proportional to F squared
so it's in it's proportional to 1 over F
squared which means the short focal
length should give a much higher depth
of field which is the case here as you
see the front subject and the back
subject are both in Focus versus with
the longer focal length the main subject
that we actually focused on of course is
in Focus but the back one
not in Focus because the depth of field
got reduced
then the second thing to look at is uh
the effect of focusing distance so it
varies the depth of field varies could
radically with focusing distance uh and
that's what is Illustrated here so again
everything is kept uh the same except
you for for this experiment and first we
have a small U so the the camera was
just three feet uh away from the from
the front subject that we focused on and
then we moved back basically the the
camera moved back to 10 feet and uh with
that we now get a longer depth of field
so both subjects are are now in Focus
versus in the first one uh the Pax
object was out of focus okay so
hopefully with this uh it's it's kind of
uh clear how how all these you know
trade-offs work and different parameters
affect uh the depth of field so this
kind of concludes the discussion about
lenses so we covered you know the
geometric optics the image formation
through lenses and also we specifically
talked about the focal length and the F
number of the lenses and how the F
number controls the field of view of the
image and the N along with other
parameters uh mainly controls the depth
of field
of field uh well as we saw F also
contributes to uh depth of field
um okay so so that's that's about lenses
uh next uh um topic we want to talk
about is Digital Image sensors and the
physics office and the electronics of it
and how these image sensors are are
built and and operate so
um there's there's different types of
digital image sensors
um and different architectures and
different constructions the two main
ones are called uh complementary metal
oxide semiconductor or CMOS sensors so
that's one
um you know semiconductor process and
architecture that is used to build a
digital image sensors and the second
type is called charge coupled devices or
ccds okay these are both used they're
both diploid uh and there is a number of
trade-offs between these two
architectures so they have different
noise levels so for instance ccds are
less noisy than cmoses typically the
speeds are are different cmoses are
typically faster than ccds the
sensitivity levels are are different
costs is different and other factors uh
we will only study CMOS sensors uh in
detail because uh those are the ones
that are mostly used in um you know more
cheaper more robust Imaging sensors that
are used in robotics CMOS sensors are
more flexible they're cheaper and the
performance is pretty good it's maybe
not as good as the best CC these out
there but they're they're very good
sensors and here's one image of 120
megapixel CMOS sensor
from Canon and that's that's what the
thing is looks like it's it's pretty
small I mean this this is a few
centimeters in in diameter basically and
diagonally basic
um okay so so so let's talk about the
CMOS sensors
um the type of CMOS sensor we'll talk
about uh it's called the active pixel
sensor or CMOS APS and a CMOS APS
consists of an array of of active
photosensitive pixels okay so each of
those pixels in the sensor becomes one
pixel in the final image basically
and each pixel uh has consists of three
main components okay first is the
photosensitive component in the pixel uh
which is a reverse biased uh pin
photodiode so that's the part of the
pixel which converts incident light or
photons to an electrical signal and this
is exactly the same as lidar right so we
in great detail we talked about pi and
photodiodes and you know why they're
reversed by us how they operate what's
the responsivity and and all that so so
this is exactly the same uh different
materials because
for instance if you're making a visible
light camera we are not going to use an
in-gas you know Pion diode which is most
responsive at 1550 nanometers we will
use a silicon but same physics right so
we're not going to talk more about you
know the principles of pin because it's
exactly the same as what was covered in
writer then the other two components in
every pixel of a CMOS APS is the readout
circuitry and the readout circuitry what
it does is that it it kind of sends the
signal the electrical signal that you
get out of the PD or a photodiode and it
sends it to the adcs to be digitized so
that's a readout circuitry
and it needs to be architected and
designed such that you can read out
every pixel in in this APS array and and
remember that modern sensors have many
many pixels right you can have millions
of pixels so it's important to have you
know an architecture that can you know
nicely read out all the pixels without
crosstalk or congestion or anything like
that
and then there's a reset circuitry and
the reset circuitry essentially it it
controls exposure duration per image
frame remember that especially if you're
taking videos you want to you know take
consecutive frames
um and each frame you want to you know
start start clean so you want to reset
all the pixels and start exposure and
then at the end of the exposure duration
read out the final signal and then reset
them again and and repeat so the reset
circuitry you know makes sure that at
the beginning of every exposure for
every frame all the signals are you know
reset to the same Baseline and there's
no effect from the previous pick frame
to the next one so that's the job of the
reset circuitry
there's different you know electrical
designs for uh to to achieve uh you know
the the the this this architecture
basically the simplest possible APS
sensor uses just three mosfet
transistors uh to build the reset and
readout circuitry and this is as of
today uh the this design which is called
the 3T CMOS APS 3t43 transistor and then
it's the CMOS APS it's the the the most
you know uh uh uh most deployed
um
architecture for these you know small
cheap cameras uh that that are used in
cell phones and you know in robotics and
other applications
um so it's it's simple but it's
extremely you know well thought out and
practical and good performing and it's
it's it's used a lot today so it's not
like we'll talk about something simple
but it's so simple that it's not useful
no the what what we'll show you is
actually what you open up any camera
that's that's actually most of them are
using this this architecture
okay so uh we're gonna talk in detail
about you know how each pixel works in
the actual circuit uh but first let's
um do a quick you know uh refresher
about mosfet transistors and how how
they operate
so muscle transistor
um you're gonna you know at super high
level just just cover the part of it
that is required for understanding the
CMOS APS 3T uh pixel
um but
um remember that a transistor a mosfet
transistor it's it's a three terminal
device as shown here so it has a gate uh
shown with G that's one terminal and
then it has a drain shown as d and a
source so is s
and there is you know lots of different
things you can do with with these
transistors you can you know operate
them in different regions there's linear
regime or saturation region and result
threshold and so on and so forth and you
can build you know lots of different
circuits with different for different
applications with this but specifically
for for Imaging in the 3T APS design
um
these transistors are mainly used as
switches okay so they're either on or
off basically uh and the way the switch
works so so
um the the digital switch works is that
as shown in this picture uh with the
three terminals you can you can Define
two voltages one is the voltage between
the gate and the source vgs and the
other one is the voltage between the
drain and the source VDS and typically
there's almost no current following
through the gate so so the the IG is is
almost zero because this is a very high
impedance terminal and that's why it's
kind of shown as a capacitor here so
there's almost no no no no no current or
no DC current basically going through
that's their High terminal uh input and
then the main current path is is from
drain to the source and that's this IDs
okay so when we say these
um can be operated as switches there's
switches for that IDs you can either
have ideas go through or you can turn it
turn off the switch and then there's no
IDs no drain Source current
and the way uh it it works it's
controlled mainly by by this vgs voltage
so if this vgs is less than the
threshold voltage of the device and the
threshold voltage is the voltage that is
determined by you know the actual
geometry and material construction of
the these transistors it's typically
soft one volt it can be around mostly
0.7 volts some devices have lower V
thresholds some have slightly higher but
that's the ballpark number so if the
gate
Source voltage applied is less than the
threshold there's going to be no current
flowing through the device and that's
where the switch is off and then if you
have a vgs bigger than V threshold and
also the drain Source voltage is bigger
than vgs minus V threshold that's where
the switch is on and then you you get
the current flowing through drain Source
path which is proportional to vgs minus
V threshold squared okay and that's
where the switch is on okay so so that's
how how
in in the AP in the 3T APS pixel that's
mostly how the transistors are upgraded
so we are going to control the vgs and
then turn the switches basically on and
off and and this plot here kind of shows
the the IDS which is the current as a
function of VDS and and vgs minus we
threshold so each curve is for different
value of of vgs minus V threshold as you
see like they have one volt here two
three four and so on and then as we said
we're gonna operate these transistors in
the in the saturation region excuse me
so the saturation region is the region
to the right of this red curve
uh so so that's where uh basically this
condition is satisfied that's for for
saturation and then as as you see as as
we increase uh the vgs minus uh vth for
a fixed uh VDS the current value is
going up quite radically
um if you just you know follow this it
goes up quadratically this quadratic
current thing doesn't really matter for
um uh for the operation of the 3D APS
what matters is that we can we can just
turn the switch on and off you're going
to just apply either vgs equals zero
which turns the switch off or vgs
some constant value of vgs that is
bigger than V threshold to turn on the
switch so we we operated in like a
digital mode
um so that's why
this expression doesn't really matter
much because it's going to be either no
current going through it or some
constant current uh basically going
through it okay so that's the principle
of operation of the muscle transistor
not the full principle but the part that
is relevant to the 3T APS pixel and now
let's look at the actual pixel
architecture so this is what is really
really important so let's make sure you
know every detail that we talk about
here is uh it makes sense and and uh is
well understood because this is at the
core of essentially how these digital
cameras work so
uh what we're looking at here is just
one pixel one image pixel in a CMOS APS
sensor 33 pixel and as mentioned so
we'll have our we have our PI and photo
diode so so so that's that's this guy
here and in parallel to it in blue we
are showing the parasitic capacitance of
the diode okay so that's not an external
capacitor component that's why it's
shown in blue that's just a parasitic
capacitance that every pin photodiode
has right
um where we're showing there and then
um
there is three transistors here one is
for resetting that's this m reset uh the
other one is for readout it's called M
select and this third one uh msf it
basically makes a buffer
um for for readout circuitry that we'll
we'll talk more about and then there's
two control signals that you can apply
to every pixel there's a reset control
signal and there is what what is called
a row select uh
basically a control signal and these are
digital signals so it's either zero or
or one right so and that's how we
control the switches so when when this
when the control signal is zero that
corresponding switch is off and then you
apply one and and and and and it turns
on the switch basically
um so digital control and let's start
with um you know at the start of a frame
so let's say that's time times zero and
here on the right we are plotting the
control signals and we are looking at
the V out which is which is the voltage
at the at the output of the of the of
the of the pixel right uh so that's
that's that's the uh the output of the
pin photodi okay so at the beginning of
the frame we apply a reset signal a
short pulse okay so we briefly turn on
the switch and what happens when the
switch turns on basically this this we
we reset uh gets gets a flight here
right so current uh flows through and we
basically charge up this parasitic
capacitance
to the voltage that is set by this V
reset voltage right right so you close
your reset switch and you basically set
your V out to be equal to the reset
right then exposure starts and by
exposure we mean light is is going to
hit the photo diode and it's going to
generate some photo current right and if
you follow the path of this current and
remember now uh the only way the current
can can flow in the circuit is by
discharging this capacitor going through
the diode to the ground because this
switch is closed so there's no path here
and also if you look at this buffer
mosfet here as we said the gate has a
very high impedance input so there's
also no current going this way right
into that mosfet so so the current needs
to basically discharge the capacitor
right and
and so what happens if you follow V out
as as during the exposure it's going to
start basically discharging the
capacitor until the exposure time is
over okay and then at the end of the
exposure time we are going to apply a
short pulse to the row select
okay so what row select does is note
that it's going to the to the to the
gate of our select transistor so it's
going to turn on or close this switch
here
okay and I'm gonna just clean up a
little bit to explain what's what's
happening here so this this transistor
this is forming a buffer for us
and this specific configuration here is
called a source follower
that's why it's called SF
and it's a voltage buffer so what this
does if I if I draw it again here the
the the source follower so there's vdd
applied here and then there's this V out
and here it's it's going to the other
transistor but the way the source
follower works is that
um it's it's like an ideal buffer so
it's a it's a it's an amplifier with a
voltage gain of one so the voltage at
this output at this at the at the source
is uh this vs is almost equal to the to
the voltage of the gate which in our
case is V out okay so it basically
buffers the voltage but because this
input is very high impedance it doesn't
draw current and the reason we need this
is that without this if we directly
connect our diode to some low impedance
path uh we're gonna just very quickly
drain this capacitor and we don't want
to disturb it you know we want the
voltage of the capacitor to be only
affected by the photo current and
nothing else and that's why we add this
this buffer so the voltage here at this
note is also equal to the out that's the
effect of our buffer and that means when
we apply the the the the the pulse the
the the uh you know the control signal
to the row select and we close this
select switch
on this wire basically which we call V
column we are going to read the output
voltage of our photodiode right so again
our V out is going to drop during the
exposure time because if the
photocurrent discharging diversity
capacitor and at the output as soon as
we apply the row select this this output
voltage which we call V column
right it's going to get set to equal to
the V out at the end of the exposure
duration so we call them as V out at
time T which is the end of the exposure
which is equal to the initial value the
reset value minus Delta V and Delta V is
like how much we discharged our Junction
capacitance within the exposure duration
after
so we first apply our row select and
read out the junction voltage and then
we apply another reset pulse to the
reset input and set it back to preset
and then we expose again for our next
frame right so this is like
frame one
and then this is the next frame which is
framed now specifically what Delta V is
Delta V again is the the the voltage
drop of the capacitor the C uh because
of the photocurrent um so it's equal to
one over c times the integral of the
photocrine IP uh we'll send the exposure
duration so T going from 0 to Big T and
uh assuming because these exposure
durations are very short these are like
milliseconds right uh IP is not going to
change it's like we can assume you know
fixed power is hitting your photodial uh
causing or generating a fixed photo
current so so we just get IP then the
integral becomes just T so we get IP
times T over C and remember from our
discussion in lidar that the photo
current is equal to the responsivity of
the diode times the incident Optical
power so Delta V basically becomes
responsivity times the optical power
that's hitting that pixel and times the
exposure duration divided by The
Junction capacitance the point is at the
end of the day if you plug this in the
the readout voltage from this this
column line uh is is a linear function
is linear in the incident Optical power
right so our image sensor each pixel
would actually measure something that is
a linear function of the optical power
that was incident on it and that's a
proper you know uh Optical sensor an
image sensor every pixel measures how
much how much light was uh was hitting
it
okay so
um
here's a picture okay how now you can
excale this right so we looked at just
one pixel this is the image we looked at
and we know how that that works that's
the 3T APS pixel and now that's the
magic of you know semiconductor
manufacturing process that you can have
millions of these right and build a big
big array with millions of pixels and
you know cover a large area and then you
know uh use that to form images here's a
picture of an 8x8 pixel array and the
way the the full you know image sensor
works is that you see uh you have rows
and Columns of pixel so it's going to
apply a row select signal to rows one by
one so so that's uh uh basically this
this row select signal that that we had
here so when a row select is applied
basically
the readout transistors or the select
transistors on all the pixels and that
Pro are gonna get turned on and the
corresponding voltages for those pixels
are gonna
be available on these column traces
right and all of that go through some
you know uh
multiplexer demultiplexer and get fed to
the to the ADC so that's how you
digitize you know the the voltages that
are read from from every pixel so you do
one row and then it selects the next row
and then it selects an extra so each row
is selected and all the columns are
basically voltages are being fed to the
ADC and you basically digitize uh one
one row at a time and there's also of
course the reset signals that that go to
all pixels so after you read all your
rows and columns for one frame you reset
everything and and you do that again
um so that's that's the basic operating
principle of the CMOS apfs now
if you look at this pixel structure here
you see there's there's of course the
photosensitive component which is the
PIN photodiode but you also have you
know the three transistors and the wires
and these take up
um some of your you know uh
semiconductor area so not the entire
area of of your semiconductor is going
to be photosensitive
um
and uh so so this is for instance a
picture showing you know if if you look
at just one pixel you have your photo
diode there
um but a lot of surface areas you know
taken up by the transistors and the the
you know these bus traces for uh row
select and reset and other things so
because of that if if you just you know
shine light on that a lot of the light
is going to hit these non-photosensitive
parts of the of the device and basically
get wasted
um a way to improve that is is to add
micro lenses on top of all the pixels
and what the micro lens does is that it
focuses rays of light bends them and
focuses them into the uh photosensitive
area so here's a electron microscope you
know a cross-section image of of one
pixel so you have the micro lens at the
top let's just curved structure and you
see see Razer flight that that come
through they all get bent and and they
get focused into the photodiode area
without the micro lens these Rays would
have just hit you know the transistors
and and other things and and that light
would not be sensed basically so the
micro lens array and and here you see an
array of them there's like these little
bubbles uh they're typically you know
added on top of the
similar sensor to improve the so-called
fill factor or the light collection
efficiency of the of the sensor okay so
that's one the other thing we need to
talk about is that okay
um how do we actually sense color
because
um the the basically the architecture we
have so far described every pixel would
just measure the total
power that's incident on it and if the
semiconductor Pim photodiode like a
silicon pin photodiode is is sensitive
to you know
all the visible light wavelengths that
each pixel would measure essentially all
an average of all colors so we cannot
form a color image out of it we can only
form a intensity image or like a black
and white Type image out of it so
there's different ways that you can
sense color
um the most common one is by adding
another another layer which which goes
between the uh the the you know
semiconductor uh pixels and the and the
micro lenses so there's micro lenses on
top and then there is this color filter
array that's added underneath the the
micro lens so in this picture
um you see you have the micro lens on
top then you have the color filter and
then you have the actual pixel at the
bottom and the color filter it's you
know it's it has the same pixel
structure as the as the sensor itself
but but each cell and the in the color
array mostly just lets one color of of
light through right and so you can have
like an RGB type uh color filter or CFA
color filter array and this is this is
what happens so you get you know light
with a full full spectrum light hitting
the color filter array but if it's the
red pixel it only lets red light through
or the green only lets green through or
the blue only lets blue color through so
so
um here is one example of the spectral
response of the three different colors
and the color filter array so as you see
the blue is you know centered around 450
uh nanometers the green is centered
around uh 540 nanometers and the red is
centered around 650 nanometers so each
of them predominantly
lets one color through which means the
pixel that is underneath each of these
you know colors mostly senses one color
right so then
um the pixels under the red
CFA cells only sends thread the pixels
under the green CFA cells on the
sunscreen and the pixels under blue CFA
Rays only sends blue this is one way of
you know making your
image sensor color sensitive there's
there's other less common uh
Technologies
um just so you know but most the cameras
today use color filter now there's also
different designs for the color filters
like how what's the pattern of this RGB
cells that you want to use in the color
filter array and the most common one is
is called the buyer filter
and the way the buyer filter is designed
it this is this is the the pattern of
the buyer filter shown here the
immediate thing you would uh notice is
that it has twice as many uh like if you
look at this this little two by two
square here it has two greens
and one red and one blue so it has twice
as many green cells as red and blue and
that was a design choice that was made
such that this color filter array mimics
the physiology of the human eye so the
human eyes it turns out that they're
more sensitive to green color than red
and blue and then that's why this is
specific CFA was designed to have a
response very similar to human eye so
that the pictures the color pictures you
get out of it look natural to the to the
human eye so with this what we get is
that let's say this is the original
scene that you're trying to to image and
then let's say it was 120 by 80 pixel
sensor
and the actual output what the with the
with the buyer filter it looks like a
mosaic uh so if I if I zoom in here
before any processing every every uh
pixel at the at the output if you color
code them every pixel would either be
just sensing red or green or blue so it
looks like you see again if you zoom in
even further every pixel is just sensing
the light intensity at at one specific
color so it looks like this weird Mosaic
instead of you know natural natural
image you would expect like that and uh
that's something that is taken care of
in in DSP so so there's some
interpolation that we need to do and
basically for every pixel by looking at
the neighboring ones for every pixel we
need an r and a g and a b value right to
get the full color of of that pixel uh
but out of the sensor every pixel only
gives you one of the three naturally
measured so the other two colors need to
be interpolated from neighboring pixels
and that's the job of the D Mosaic King
algorithms that run uh in DSP uh so the
images that we get out of the cameras
never look like this Mosaic here there's
always some interpolation applied and
then we get a more naturally looking
image where every pixel is interpolated
to have rgnb instead of just one of the
three we'll talk more about the Mosaic
King but that's just so you know
okay so this kind of uh completes the
discussion of how the digital image
sensor works or the specific one we
talked about which was the 3T CMOS APS
which is the most common type of you
know image sensor used today uh and now
we are already
um so we talked about the physics and
the electronics now we can look at the
you know the full system architecture of
a of a vision sensor so this is the full
um architecture diagram
so um as as we discussed there's always
some Imaging Optics or lenses that we
talked about and then
um
the image comes to focus on the image
sensor plane and we talked about how the
image sensor works and how different
different components that go into it and
then the readouts of all the pixels get
digitized through the ADC and then there
is a number of signal processing steps
that needs to happen before a final
image is produced that looks natural and
and you know expected and that's the job
of this image signal processor or ISP
module inside cameras and and usually so
the cameras have you know a a hardware
module a chip that that applies
different you know signal processing
steps to the digitized readouts of the
of the uh of the sensor and the job of
that is to basically convert this RGB
Mosaic that you get out of the sensor to
a natural looking uh image specifically
there's multiple steps that happen
inside the ISP there's of course the
demosaic or the color interpolation that
we call talked about and there is a
white balancing in tone mapping
um there's some denoising and image
sharpening that typically happens and
also it can compress the image to you
know require less storage and after all
of that the final image is is produced
that can be stored on you know some
storage media now note that when it
comes to the ISP every camera uses
different algorithms in their ISP and
most of these are proprietary to the
camera manufacturer and we don't know
exactly like you get like what what is
running on your iPhone or your Android
phone or your Canon or your Nikon phone
or any other you know or your Sony phone
or whatever they are all different uh
generally they do most of these you know
functions that are shown here but they
can do them in different orders and the
specific algorithms they use to achieve
each of these functions uh shown here
are proprietary and they vary a lot from
different manufacturers so we're going
to high level describe you know what
what at the functional level what these
what each of these you know blocks
um try to achieve and we also talk about
some very simple algorithms that can
achieve those functions but note again
that we are not talking about you know
state-of-the-art based kind of
algorithms that that one could do here
um if you're just you know barely
scratching the surface and uh but
nevertheless I think it's valuable to
you know understand what each of these
you know terms mean what's the the goal
of them and and know about at least the
simplest type of algorithm that can
achieve that
um but if you
you know I want to work on an ISP I do
not recommend you know implementing the
algorithms that are discussed here
because these are very simple and they
typically don't don't uh work super well
compared to the state of the art you
should you know uh come up with or or
learn uh much much better uh
sophisticated algorithms to achieve
these okay so we're going to start with
uh color interpolation or or di Mosaic
King
um and and again as we said the natural
uh signal that you get out of out of
your your image sensor the ones that
have these color filters is this RGB
Mosaic where every pixel has just one
color and then the job of the Mosaic
King is that uh interpolate the color so
that we get R and G and B value for
every pixel and we get an image that
looks much more natural here this image
looks pixelated that's just because
um the resolution was low it's just 181
120 by 80 pixels so that is not because
of the demos I think that it looks
pixelated it's just not that it was a
low resolution image
now the simplest algorithm that you can
do for the Mosaic King is just a linear
interpolation and the way it works is
that for every pixel okay you get one of
the three colors directly measured right
depending on what the color filter on
top of it was so you get either Rog or B
already measured so that's fine and then
for the other two colors you just
interpolate the value is linearly
interpret the values of the three
closest a four or two closest neighbors
to do that so for this one highlighted
here to get the r you average the the
four pixels at the corners of it the r
values of those and that gives you the r
for the middle pixel the G is again
that's directly measured for that same
pixel so no interpolation needed and for
Blue uh you get two nearest neighbor
pixels so you can average these two
pixels and that gives you the bloop for
that
um and and that's how you can you can do
your linear color interpolation
uh note that with this algorithm
or with any interpolation algorithm
actually because every pixel only
measures one color physically two-thirds
of the information in the final image is
actually made up and by made up I mean
it's interpolated so it's not physically
accurate but nevertheless
because color across pixels usually
doesn't change that that rapidly usually
in some cases it does
um your final image can look very
realistic and good
now with this simple
um you know linear color interpolation
in certain cases it can introduce
artifacts in the in the image uh
specifically it can in if there are
some structures in the image they can
cause color fringes or color more a uh
in the final image
notorious structures are for instance if
you have black and white detail in your
image and here is is one if I zoom in
here's an image of like a kind of a
fabric structure where it had this fine
you know black and black and white you
know fabric lines woven together in the
image and then the linear interpolation
causes these color fringes that that you
can see across across the image and uh
and and that's a failure of the the
demozaking algorithm basically that that
that has happened in this case
uh what can you do well there's more
sophisticated algorithms of course you
can use um one way is you can fix that
by using applying a median filter on the
colors so after interpolation you look
at your you know color histograms and
apply the medium filter and with that
you can remove outlier uh color changes
okay and here's one example same picture
two different ways of doing demos making
the left one I'm going to zoom in a a
little more on it that's what linear
interpolation and if you look at where
there's fine black and white structure
like this electrical wire line here or
the branches of the tree you would see
you know significant color fringes also
on the windows and other places you
would notice that and then if you apply
the median filter so if you do the
medium filtered interpolation see how
much it improves it's still not perfect
perfect but it's significantly improved
with respect to fringes and more
okay so that's about uh d mosaican
uh the other thing that happens in the
ISP typically is is white balancing and
my balancing basically what it tries to
do it tries to ensure that the white
color is represented Faithfully in the
image okay and why is that necessary
it's because
um different lighting conditions can
change the appearance of colors right
and this is something that our brains
have been evolved to just take care of
so well that we really don't notice it
um in our vision so for instance if you
have a white piece of paper and you and
you take it under a very warm light
source like sunlight or you take it
under a very cold light source like
fluorescent light the actual color
that's coming out of that paper
reflected off of that paper is going to
be affected by you know the color of the
light that was incident on it and it's
going to look very different under the
two lighting conditions but our brains
this just adjusts for that and balance
it out such that white always looks
white to us almost always except if
there's like some very very weird you
know lighting condition like if you're
in a uh in a club with you know
very unnatural color lights uh then yes
colors look different but
um
otherwise in normal lighting conditions
white always looks white to us
with cameras this needs to be handled in
the SD which means
um the camera needs to somehow guess or
find out what part of the scene or what
object in that image was White in real
world
and it needs to find the RGB the sensed
RGB value for that object and then it
needs to scale all the colors all the
rgbs in the image uh proportionally
either up or down such that the chosen
RGB of the white hot object becomes one
one because RGB equals one one that's
the that's the white color right so so
that's the job of the white balancing is
like find the white thing in the image
and find the RGB value of that and scale
that RGB to one one one and scale all
the other pixels
accordingly so all the colors get get
adjusted here's one example so it's a
picture of a flower that was that was
taken and for this flower you know the
the the the the the
petals were actually white or part of
them was was wide and if you just with
the this is the raw image if you look at
the raw image with pre-processed image
and and you look at the actual color
that the sensor sensed on the flower the
RGB value was actually
0.72.8.85 and this is the actual color
here it's actually gray so white looked
grayish in that uh image in the Raw
image and then after applying white
balancing we basically scale that to one
one and scale all the rest of the RGB
values by the same scale factors and
this is the final image that you get
where the the flower actually looks
white as it would be in the real world
and all the colors look a little warmer
as a result of the white balancing
applied
no um modern cameras try to do this
automatically so there's some automatic
white button or AWB that is applied in
cameras and it's very it's a very
non-trivial task as you can imagine
because the camera needs to somehow find
or guess
what that scale factor is which means
either it needs to find something that's
white and that's a very non-trivial task
for ndsp uh or otherwise you know have
some heuristics uh there's different
different
um
algorithms
um there's many of them but here are two
that are sometimes used one is the gray
World
assumption and this algorithm basically
assumes that if you average the the
color of all the pixels in an image
um it it becomes gray so that's the gray
wall
um basically approximation so the
algorithm forces the average color of
the scene to become gray so it finds the
scaling factor that after that is
applied the average of all the pixels
becomes gray and and that is used for
for byte balancing the other one uh
algorithm looks at the brightest pixel
um so it assumes that the brightest
pixel you have in the in the in the
image that's that's the color of that is
white
and then it forces that um to to
basically become what if it's not
already and then applies the same
scaling to all the pixels
but uh neither of these algorithms are
perfect uh they can they can fail in in
in different different scenarios so for
instance the gray world uh fails when uh
the the lighting is is is is is is uh um
kind of on the extreme
um side of of warm or cold so if it's
very warm like a sunset lighting or if
it's very cold like fluorescent uh gray
water approximation can can really fail
um and then the brightest pixel uh
approximation it can fail when the your
brightest pixel is actually saturated it
was so bright that it completely
saturated the the sensor so the value
you're reading is clipped basically it's
not the real value or if it's coming
from some metallic surface that wasn't
actually white then that assumption
breaks down here's an example where the
the great world approximation failed so
this is a picture that was taken uh in
in in in during sunset with very warm
lighting as you can see so this is the
rhyming image and then with the Great
War great world Auto wide balancing
after that that is applied you get this
picture which would completely washed
out colors you can see this is not the
right right uh White balancing apply so
just so you know these algorithms they
are deployed especially the gray world
still is is is deployed
um but it's not perfect and this is one
of those cases because the task is is
such a non-trivial subjective task uh
actually modern machine learning
approaches can do really really well uh
with white balancing
um way better than what these classical
algorithms can do and that's what most
of modern cell phones they have you know
for white balancing they use machine
learning because you just you know show
them enough data with you know ground
truth white balance and then just the
network learns how to do it like the
human brain has learned to do it and
they can do really really well
especially and challenging lighting
conditions machine learning can do
really well with with white balancing
okay next thing that happens in ISP
typically is is tone mapping and uh tone
mapping is a generally speaking it it
does some adjustments to colors and it
and that's on top of white balancing so
after white balancing is done there
could be some additional adjustment to
colors and they tone wrapping can be
done for various purposes okay sometimes
it's just done for purely aesthetic
purposes just for the image to look
better and that's for instance
um if you've used Instagram and there's
always you know Instagram filters and
many of those filters are just different
tone mapping filters that look you make
your picture you know look a little more
vibrant or a little less vibrant or
black and white and this and that so
this is not a useful you know goal for
autonomy but there's other purposes for
tone mapping that could be very useful
for autonomy so for instance you can use
it to improve the dynamic range of your
image or you can use it to improve the
contrast of the image and things of that
nature could be very useful for for
sensing applications now dynamic range
note that it's the ratio of the minimum
to maximum intensity that the sensor can
record in your image and the image
contrast is typically taken as the
difference in the intensity of the of
the pixels divided by the average
intensity okay so that's the technical
definition of dynamic gradient
confidence and when it comes to tone
mapping there's two classes or types of
algorithms for tone mapping one is
called Global tone mapping and that's
where basically the same function the
same correction is applied to every
every image pixel right same function
every every image every pixel is
affected the same way or you can have
algorithms which do local tone mapping
and that's where the parameters of the
of the tone mapping function is
different for every pixel and it uses
you know some information from the
neighboring pixels to decide like is
this pixel for instance in a highlight
area in the shadow area and you know and
and things like that to be you know
smarter about how tone mapping should be
applied so generally speaking local tone
mapping can result in much better images
but of course it's a more sophisticated
type of type of algorithm
and tone mapping again is one of those
areas where many many different
algorithms exist from super super simple
ones one of which we'll talk about to
you know really Advance ones using big
machine learning models and and things
like that
um the simplest
um Global tone mapping algorithm that
actually is applied quite a quite a lot
uh is called gamma correction and and
Gamma correction it's it's a very simple
function so it just basically takes the
value of of of every pixel in the image
and raises that to some power gamma
right so you apply a value for gamma it
can be bigger than one or less than one
and you apply that same function IO
equals II to the power of gamma to every
pixel right now what is what is what is
the input what is I sub I uh it can be
you know the individual R and G and B uh
color values of every pixel that's one
way of doing gamma correction or you can
apply it just to the intensity value of
uh of everything pixel so there's you
know what what actually goes into that
gamma correction function you can decide
what it could be but here's one example
to show you how gamma correction can be
useful
so in this case we have an HDR High
dynamic range image which is this input
image and this image was captured with a
high dynamic range camera but now we're
displaying it on a medium like my iPad
display doesn't have as much dynamic
range as the image sensor so the image
looks saturated specifically if you look
at you know the highlights of of the sky
these all looks completely you know
saturated and white so we need to
compress the dynamic range but the
information is there right the actual
sensor was able to capture those
highlights but I can't display it I
don't have enough dynamic range in my
display to show that so I need to
compress the dynamic range of the image
such that I can I can show all the
details in uh on my iPad for instance
iPad display and this is you know a case
where gamma correction can work can be
very very effective so when it comes to
the image as as we said you can apply
gamma correction to the intensity so
this top image you can think of it as or
another way of instead of you know just
thinking about as RGB values you can
think of it as you know it has some
intensity information also called
luminosity and uh plus some color
information also uh called chrominance
of the
uh of the image so you can have
luminance and prominence is another way
of you know describing what the image is
so
um
when so we're gonna because we want to
do compression we're going to choose a
gamma value that's less than one so
let's say here we arbitrarily chose
gamma equals 0.5 and we're going to
apply two ways one is we apply it to
every color individually so you raise R
to the gamma B to the gamma and G to the
gamma that's way one way and this is
this is the image that we get uh note
that it got the job done right so now we
see all the details and the highlights
which we're missing in the original
original picture but the artifact or the
side effect is that it it kind of looks
washed out okay that's the trade-off
that was me here's another way of
applying so now we're applying the gamma
correction just to the intensity so
basically we just we just calculate the
intensity apply gamma correction to that
and and don't touch the chrominance and
then combine them again and then form
the final image again it gets the
compress the dynamic range compression
job done right all those details
highlights are recovered
um but the colors kind of look over
exaggerated in this one right now it's
kind of a matter of taste like which one
which one which one of these you kind of
like better or would like to use for you
know artistic reasons but for sensing
purposes both of these
are acceptable because the goal was to
recover the dynamic range or compress a
dynamic range such that on this display
I can I can show it and and both of the
these uh gamma Corrections achieve that
okay so
um last thing we want to talk about is
the last step
sharpening it is applied to to the
images and these are typically filtering
operations although you know more modern
techniques again like machine learning
can also be used
um
um like you can you can apply neural
Nets to achieve denoising and sharpening
and those would do really really well
especially the modern ones but
classically these were you know uh
implemented as filtering operations and
in their simplest forms they use linear
filtering so just basically 2D
convolutions with some filter kernels
could be used for
um denoising and sharpening here are two
examples here is a classical you know
denoising
um uh filter which is called the
gaussian blur so you take your noisy
image here's like like a zoomed in
portion of a bigger image and you
convolve that with this filter kernel
which as you see I mean it's it's it has
a high value in the center and it kind
of you know drops
um according to your okay gaussian
profile as you go away from the center
pixel and and this is just to normalize
you know the sum of all the pixel values
to to one so we don't you know saturate
the image after filtering or or or or
dim it too much and after applying this
it kind of you know Blends the value of
each pixel with the neighboring ones
with some gaussian weighted thumb and
and this is what you get so it gets the
job done you see it's it's it's it's
it's much less noisy in in all areas
um but also you lose
um um some contrast right like if you
look at this portion it's less sharp
here you get some some blurriness and
that's also in the name of the filter I
mean because we're blending the value of
neighboring pixels we get a little bit
of blurriness applied to it
and here is a one very simple sharpening
filter this is our filter kernel it has
a positive value on the center and then
the the slide pixels have negative
values so it kind of takes a difference
um of the center pixel with with the
neighbors and it enhances Edge contrast
if those pixels are at different values
it even you know enhances that and
that's the effect you know the original
picture it was very soft and then after
applying that that filter we get you
know much sharper much sharper features
again this is just to illustrate you
know the possibility of what you can do
with linear filtering when it comes to
denoising and sharpening these are by no
means the best possible you know filters
you could use but could be you know
useful for certain applications now if
you use any modern day you know
um computer vision programming Library
like opencd and python all of the
functions we talked about you know demos
a king white balancing tone mapping uh
denoising sharpening all of these uh are
already you know for each of them many
all of these are included in in these uh
you know modern libraries and for each
function there's usually you get a
variety of you know algorithms that are
already implemented and you can you know
try them and you can vary the parameters
very easily with a few lines of code and
you kind of you know see what works
better for your application so that
could really be the way to go if you are
quite not quite sure you know oh I want
to do some denoising I'm not quite sure
you know where to start you can always
go opencv is usually my go to package I
go and I you know read the documentation
okay what what they noticing are options
do I get and I try a few of them and
these are so well implemented these days
that literally you know in two lines of
code you can do that also well you could
use chat GPT of course and it's actually
pretty good when it comes to these kinds
of implementation experimentation as you
can just say hey chat GPT write me an
opencv script that you know Imports an
image in this format and it applies
gaussian blur-de-noising filter with you
know width of one and a half pixels to
it and it will do it and then you can
you know that that can be kind of like
the skeleton script that you can start
and I'm not saying you should definitely
use chat GPT but if you know you haven't
you're very unfamiliar with you know how
these packages work it could be a start
you know it could give you a place to
start and then you can experiment with
different things
okay so this concludes the
um discussion about the architecture of
division system and they and the ISP or
image signal processing steps and some
simple algorithms I want to finish this
chapter with
um just a very brief discussion about
future directions and vision systems for
for autonomy so I want to start with
saying that Vision sensors as of today
are the most important sensors in
robotics today I mean when it comes to
sensing for robotics Vision or cameras
are the king basically
uh and and that's for for
um a couple of reasons one is in terms
of you know the maturity of the hardware
um and by maturity I mean the the cost
the size the performance the power all
these key metrics cameras today are way
ahead of of other sensors they're like
orders of magnitude cheaper than Radars
and lidars they're much more robust you
can get much you know higher quality
signals and images out of them
um so that's one reason but this is not
a fundamental reason right I mean we
know cameras because of you know it
started way before robotics was a thing
and there's years and years of you know
r d and Academia and Industry behind it
so the technology is naturally more more
advanced but eventually I think other
sensors are going to catch up and get if
not exactly at the same you know Point
as cameras they're gonna close the gap
quite a bit in terms of cost and hour
and performance
but also for cameras we are benefiting
from you know many many years of of
research and development and
advancements in computer vision and and
and machine learning so most of
perception pipelines today are just
designed to work with with images and
and that really helps when it comes to
autonomy because we need to you know
make sense of
um the signals that we get out of our
sensors and
already a lot of tools and algorithms
exist that helps us make sense of camera
images so for instance if you want to do
classification on a sensor image a
sensor output for cameras you can in 10
minutes go download YOLO V8 for instance
which is
a beautiful you know really really high
quality implementation of a
classification Network and it works real
time very reliably very good performing
but if you want to do that same task on
a 3D Point cloud from a lidar or a radar
your options are much more limited
you're not as high performance you know
and you need to come up maybe with with
your own ideas and implementations again
this is not a fundamental reason right
it's just the fact that with cameras
we're benefiting from years and years of
machine computer vision and Machine
Vision r d
now also I want to note that we talked
about RGB cameras which is the most
common type of camera but there are also
other more specialized types of Imaging
sensors and some of them could be more
suitable for specific tasks in autonomy
so for instance you can get thermal
cameras they're very close to RGB
cameras they just sense at longer wave
IRS which is proportional to the
temperature
um of of different subjects but
principle of operation is is very
similar uh these days you can get stereo
camera systems which use basically two
cameras with some distance away which is
called the Baseline and then in addition
to giving the RGB image they can also
use
apply some geometric methods or some
machine learning methods to estimate
depth in the scene so they give you
point clouds which are RGB colored they
can be very useful but not that
typically the maximum depth that they
can sense is limited and it's a function
of the Baseline so to be able to get
more depth you need to space your
cameras more further apart also as a
function of the resolution of the camera
sensors but stereo cameras for
applications and Robotics where you
don't need to see that far you only need
to see like 10 20 30 meters can be a
very interesting option and then you get
more even more specialized types of
cameras like Dynamic Vision sensors
where instead of
um just measuring you know intensity
they measure time derivatives of
intensity so when they give you these
events per pixel
which could be useful for various
specific tasks and and computer vision
and autonomy
um and also I want to uh note that well
yes cameras is the most important type
of sensor today but I really believe and
in certain applications a camera only
approach to sensing could be sufficient
but in general that's not true I don't
believe that is true and that's again
because of by now I think at the end of
the quarter you know you know a lot
about the physics of sensing and uh
with that we know that for instance
cameras though have fundamental issues
with uh use cases like low light or
ultra high dynamic range scenes or low
visibility scenes where there's bad
murder like rain and fog and other
things and if you want a solution that
can cover these use cases or a solution
that
um
has requirements that a camera approach
fundamentally cannot do so for instance
if you need to
see uh very long ranges if you need to
see you know hundreds of meters with
with good accuracy even a good stereo
camera system uh would really really
struggle to achieve you know that kind
of uh depth mapping and that's where you
you're forced to use other sensing
modalities like lidar radar and sonar
and others
um and also another reason to you know
not just rely on cameras is in cases
where safety is a concern uh you need
redundancy in your sensors such that if
one modality fails the other one can
still cover you
um so for that I uh for those reasons I
think a vision only approach to autonomy
wouldn't
basically cover all use cases but it can
cover a subset of you know autonomy
applications
and I want to close with talking about
some future directions and envision
sensors so um fission sensors
um you know we have we have years of
development for for RGB cameras and they
were mostly for you know for photography
and for artistic reasons but now that
we're entering this era of robotic
autonomy there is
um you know a lot of rethinking going
into what a proper camera or a vision
system for autonomy could be or should
be and you know redesigning even the
hardware uh to be more suitable for for
those types of applications the general
trend is
um that the Future Vision sensors become
more intelligent and by more intelligent
I mean uh you you if if you zoom into
one just one pixel in Your Vision sensor
what it does today is just it basically
measures
um light intensity at a given
wavelengths basically art and red green
or blue but now we're moving to them
towards these more sophisticated cameras
that support in pixel signal processing
so every pixel has like a little brain
of its own uh well brain is of course
over exaggerating but it has you know
processing capabilities of its own and
they can be individually programmed and
then
um by being clever about you know how
you program these things uh you can
achieve like really really sophisticated
uh sensing tasks
so for instance you can uh you can do
very complex feature extractions right
by the camera you know this is not we're
not talking about ISP like at pixel
level these cameras can be programmed to
do sophisticated things
um or for instance if you have
individual control over the exposure
duration for every pixel versus the
current cameras where you have just one
fixed exposure duration for all pixels
you can have your cameras you know do
ultra high dynamic range Imaging like
things like 130 DB of dynamic range have
been you know demonstrated which is
unheard of In classical cameras you can
do much better depth estimation much
better tracking and other you know tasks
that are very relevant to autonomy and
the way this is achieved at the hardware
level is this is one very interesting
way of of thinking about it so we have
this access here shown by an arrow where
as you go from left to right your
cameras or every pixel in the camera
Hardware is becoming more intelligent
and the way that is done is is by having
know more transistors per pixel which
means more logic or more signal
processing capabilities per pixel so at
the far left we have you know our our
pretty pretty unintelligent just the 3T
APS pixel with and this is the numbers
or you know number of transistors order
of magnitude per pixel so this is 2 to
the one to the two slightly more
sophisticated than the 3T APS so you can
have the log pixel which is basically an
APS with improve dynamic range but with
some trade-offs then you get to
something like two to the four two to
the five order magnitude transistors per
pixels you can have the dynamic Vision
sensor pixel here which has you know
kind of you can break it down into three
pieces there's the photoreceptor piece
then there's this
differencing circuit which kind of takes
the time derivative of of intensity per
pixel and then there's some comparative
so disk already can do you know more
sophisticated things per pixel and then
you go even further to you know two to
the 80 to the nine transistors per pixel
and then that's where you get things
like Scamp which is a very interesting
type of camera which has almost general
purpose programmable pixel I'm not going
to go into the details of it but there's
a lot that you can do with these types
of sensors now today they're not widely
commercially deployed and they come with
a lot of trade-offs main one being as
you increase the number of transistors
as you know if you want to keep in all
the high resolution that means the photo
well these transistors take area right
in the in the Silicon wafer so the
photosensitive area becomes a smaller
and smaller and smaller which means
you're going to be you know your live
collection efficiency uh is is going to
become become lower and lower which is a
which is a big trade-off so because of
that I mean these these these uh ideas I
mean they have been deployed they're
they're research in research communities
very interesting things that are being
done with them but I think there is
still years away from you know becoming
becoming mainstream and of course I mean
sky is the limit like I'm very curious
to see you know as we go to even more
transistors per pixel which means I can
do more sophisticated kind of logic and
where do we land like could we
eventually have cameras where you have
you know a full neural net per pixel
that's doing something very very
sophisticated I don't know maybe okay so
that's uh my take on future directions
and vision sensors and I think with this
we can conclude the chapter on on on
cameras and vision systems and and of
course I again I hope uh I hope you
found the course uh useful and
interesting thank you and have a nice
summer